was probably brand new with dishearten
the tonton I could put the ball in the
endzone put a fat [ __ ] in the
friendzone this [ __ ] sound like an intro
just won't give me that tempo those guys
they're free smoke on the west coast
yeah I'm talking about free Rose dark
haired [ __ ] she look like she go she
hometown hero feeling myself came her to
my ego she headed my deep so she said
babies I heard when I deep though but if
I freaked ho hang around us and she's
learning my lingo back down was worried
about me though in the gym trying to
work on my free top down spending money
in the club like sound yes ma'am she a
little freak on count but she won't put
this on the ground road boys try to diss
on the ground I can't switch on the fan
[ __ ] I hit the switch on this one my
head is we used to share a connection
now it just feels like it's Brandon
stretch
places somewhere in there's a lesson
yelling involving is very depressing I'm
at the club with the basketball team in
the front section under the water and
wear protection got a career and I'm
very invested some people call it a
scary obsession I like it call it a
passion I can be sitting with legs PG we
getting some traction I'm at the venue
was packed
oh I'm diggin her exit I got a baby
Simon on me and she trying to get it
impressive
that's my distraction that's my time
she's come on anybody get a brand new
shoes for the bed they said y'all wasn't
tuned in breaking my sweat what's poppin
brand new we're just hard to
body got rid of them Tyson sports in
tatata
[Music]
[Applause]